-...the scope of exactly how far
country music reaches,
'cause you're
a West Virginia guy.
-Right.
-You live in Tennessee.
But you go -- you actually tour
in Europe.
You go to places -- You're going
to Scandinavia? Or...
-We were just in Sweden...
-Just got --
-...and Norway, which is...
-Okay, gotcha.
-It's so much fun for me
because I'm exotic...
-Yeah.
-...over there. I'm the...
I'm the definition
of "not exotic" in America.
-That's true.
Nobody says, like,
"Oh, that's
an interesting-looking..."
-Right.
-"...weird thing
I've never seen before."
-Yeah. For them -- They show up,
they've got the hats,
they got chaps.
I mean, they're ready.
-Do they know that nobody
wears chaps over here anymore?
-No. They're not...
-Okay. Gotcha.
-They think they're doing
the right thing.
It's fantastic, though,
to go over there
'cause they just seem
to love it.
They're sort of starved for it
in -- in these countries.
-But also -- They're not
just checking this out
to see what
country music's like.
They know...
-No.
-They're huge fans? They know
the words? They sing along?
-They know -- They have --
They speak way better English
than my band.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-They're -- they're really...
-[ Laughs ]
-I mean,
it's their second language,
but they're better at it
than us.
-Yeah.
-And...
-No, its really impressive.
-They know the words.
They -- It's really neat.
I love going over there
every now and then and...
-That's great.
Well, welcome home.
This is also cool.
I always know you --
You're a fan of comedy. You host
the CMAs with Carrie Underwood.
You guys are great.
-Thank you.
-Your songs -- A lot of
your songs are really funny.
And this is cool that you're
doing this Netflix special.
Tell us about that.
-Yeah, you know,
it's -- it's interesting.
I love the idea that
between songs
is the challenge for
the musician.
-You know.
-Yeah.
-You get out there
and it's like --
-I learned a long time ago that
if you entertain between songs,
it's gravy.
It's like -- People were like,
"Oh, wow! That was even
entertaining."
So I really worked on
the comedy chops for a while
and started hosting this thing
at our comedy festival
in Nashville
called "The Wild West
Comedy Festival,"
which...that title makes
no sense.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-It's east.
But we had a great time, and
I've got a bunch of comedians.
And we stand up there and --
and tell a bunch of jokes.
And Netflix approached and said,
"Would you like to film that
for a special?"
And we did, and it's a blast.
-Well, it's also --
I've been at concerts before.
I've been to your concerts.
And there's also that thing of
musicians when they tell a joke,
the audiences...
-Right.
-...love them because you're
also a musician.
-Right. And that -- Right.
-Like, with comedians,
there's not -- if you bomb,
you can't say,
"All right, let me get you back
with a song."
-Right. Exactly. No.
-Yeah.
-And it's also the kind of thing
where they buy a ticket
to see music,
and when you're funny,
it's just so --
it's so refreshing for them,
as opposed to if they go
to see you,
and you're not funny,
they got nothing.
-Nothing.
-I mean, absolutely...
-Well, it also makes sense
because I do feel,
particularly with you --
and I feel like this is true
of a lot
of country music singers --
I feel like
your fan base really...
feels like they know you.
Like, there's not a wall
of stardom between the two.
And because they know you,
I think they really like,
"Oh, this is --
We're actually --
He's telling us jokes. He feels
like he knows us, too."
-I think that's an --
Yeah, it's an important thing
about country music, is we're
not supposed to be the ones
who are way out of touch
and flying around
on the private jets
and everything,
even though we're completely
out of touch.
-Yeah. Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-Absolutely.
-You wear a -- You get
a new hat every morning.
-Yeah. Exactly. No.
-You throw it out in the garbage
at the end of the day.
-I throw it away.
Yeah, no, I can't wearing --
-You also --
You're really a great lyricist.
-Thank you.
-You're a fantastic
guitar player.
And you got to design
your own guitar this year.
-Yeah.
-This is a Fender?
-Fender recently just came out
with a Brad Paisley Telecaster.
-That's great.
So how -- What do they --
When you design it, like,
what are they asking you for?
Like, what input do you give?
-You made that sound like
they're crazy...
-Yeah.
-...for -- for going...
-Well, I just feel like,
would --
can you tell them things
that are crazy?
-What are they asking?
-Are you like, "50 strings!"
Like, what?
-Right.
That would be interesting.
-Yeah, that would be good,
right?
-No, basically, they want to --
They want to basically
make something that incorporates
the things you like about
their Teles.
-And now is that what you play?
Is that one of the things
you play?
-It is.
I'm gonna play it tonight.
-All right. That's great.
That's very exciting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We talked about this
on the show,
the first time you were
which was the very first week
of the show.
We met because you played --
You were kind enough
to play at my wedding.
-I was, which --
-You played our first dance.
-I was desperate.
[ Audience "Aws" ]
-It was -- And it was great.
And my wife,
you surprised my wife.
-I did.
-I knew you were coming.
And here's a photo to show
exactly how surprised
my wife was.
There she is. And, uh...
[ Laughter ]
And I was saying this to you
earlier today.
It was heartbreaking 'cause she
had not looked that happy
over the course
of the entire day.
-Yeah. No, she -- Yeah.
-I felt like the whole day,
she was looking at me like,
"Don't blow this."
-Right.
-And then you showed up,
and it was, like, "Aah!"
-It was really weird for me
because I was approached...
I don't know,
what was it, 48 hours?
-Yeah, you were not given
a ton of time.
-I was like, "This is a prank."
-[ Laughs ]
-But I was a big fan.
I think you're brilliant,
and I thought it would be fun
to go do.
-It was great.
-And I didn't regret it
one minute.
-And you played
this beautiful song
called "She's Everything."
-I did. I did that.
-And now I heard you actually
have director's cuts
of some of your songs...
-Yeah.
-...which are --
you re-write lyrics.
-In the comedy special,
actually. Let me --
What we have here?
-There you go.
-One of the things that we --
that I did trying to figure out
what the heck I was gonna
talk about...
♪♪♪♪
...was the director's cuts.
You know,
director's cuts in movies,
where they have the clips
that didn't make the film.
-Yeah.
-'Cause "She's Everything"
is a very sweet song.
-It's a perfect, like,
first dance at a wedding song.
-But what if there's lines
that are more realistic?
Especially now that you're
married, you'll understand.
-Okay, got it. So this sort of
the director's cut marriage -
-Right, it's sort of...
-Okay, got it.
♪♪ She's a yellow pair
of runnin' shoes ♪♪
♪♪ A holey pair of jeans ♪♪
♪♪ She looks great
in cheap sunglasses ♪♪
♪♪ She's a passive-aggressive
little thing ♪♪
[ Laughter ]
♪♪ She's almost everything
I ever wanted ♪♪
♪♪ Almost everything I need -- ♪♪
You know what I mean?
-Yeah. [ Laughing ]
-As opposed to, you know...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm not quite --
We're not quite there yet.
-Right, right, right.
That's one of the things in
the comedy special that we do,
is we dissect
a few of the songs.
Like, you know, the current
single that I'm doing,
there's a few versions
of that as well.
-Well, that's great. Well, I'm
so glad you're sticking around
and doing some music for us.
It's always great to see you,
buddy.
-Thank you.
-Give it up for Brad Paisley!